foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and talk about another TV show
specifically Law and Order the wildly
popular franchise that's been on TV for
decades treating us to incredible
dialogue like this
do you think that there was a reason
that the killer sodomized your husband
with a banana now that that is acting
right there even if I wasn't listening
to the words coming out of Mariska hog
attack's mouth I would know based on her
delivery alone that the killer had
sodomized this person's husband with a
banana and then she was simply trying to
figure out why why now it turns out the
victim's wife actually answered that
question and think of the funniest
possible response you're wrong it's this
do you think that there was a reason
that the killer sodomized your husband
with a banana
he was allergic to bananas excellent
simply love the idea of a killer asking
before I murder and sodomize you I've
got just one question do you have any
allergies I should be aware of
that exchange is just one of the reasons
why Law and Order is the king of cop
shows between all its various spin-offs
there are over 1200 episodes of it it's
been around for so long it is genuinely
hard to think of an actor who hasn't
appeared on it at some point because
it's featured everyone from Chevy Chase
to Samuel L Jackson to Philip Seymour
Hoffman to Angela Lansbury appearing
with her lawyer Bradley Cooper to Adam
Driver who's on Series 13 episode 11 of
SVU for approximately 3 minutes and 32
seconds of screen time if you're the
kind of person who counts that sort of
thing
even politicians have been on it like
Rudy Giuliani Mike Bloomberg and Joe
Biden all of whom guests start as
themselves which is a little weird
although it would clearly be weirder if
Biden appeared as someone else like a
Times Square Ninja Turtle who stumbled
across a grisly murder victim suffering
from banana phalactic shock Law and
Order is on all the time and for many it
is Comfort TV but it and shows like it
have a real impact one study found
viewers of crime dramas are more likely
to believe the police are successful at
lowering crime use Force only when
necessary and that misconduct does not
typically lead to false confessions
which would be great if it were true but
if you're watching this show you
probably know it is not and Law and
Order in particular has become an
American institution with huge cultural
influence some have argued its formula
shaped a generation's understanding of
the legal system and you've probably
seen people using it as a go-to
reference point like this I'm not an
attorney I watch Law and Order and from
time to time my legal experience is
watching like a Law and Order and Law
and Order SVU I think with average
viewer of Law and Order probably knows
that you're not supposed to do this well
I went to a great law school but most of
what I do on a day-to-day basis is based
off of what I learned on Law and Order
so
there is nothing you can learn from Law
and Order I've learned a ton from iced
Tea's Twitter feed alone where he drops
truth bombs like a real nut feels like
every bone in your body comes out the
head of your dick say no more I'm done
fall asleep in two minutes look the man
is a truth teller if you can't handle
the ice stay out of the freezer
it can be genuinely alarming just how
seriously some people take the show in
fact just listen to war and light law
and order svus form a long time
showrunner talk about an unexpected
group of viewers that he learned about
we've also found out over time and this
is a little
uh anxiety provoking for me that a lot
of cops aren't trained in how to
um how to do their job in second cases
of sexual assault and a lot of cops get
a lot of their information from watching
SVU which uh a lot of police departments
don't have the time or the money to to
put people through formal training yeah
that's not great is it nobody should be
learning how to do their job from a TV
show unless of course your job happens
to be telling jokes to mask your
deep-seated feelings of emptiness and
existential dread in which case keep
watching you might pick up some tips
so if Law and Order is being co-signed
by elected leaders and everyone from TV
pundits to actual cops are using it to
learn about law enforcement we thought
tonight we take a look at what this
franchise has actually been teaching us
and let's start with the fact that the
line between cop shows and actual cops
has always been deliberately blurry in
fact the first Smash Hit cop show
Dragnet which debuted on TV in 1951 made
a big selling point of its authenticity
right from the start part of each
episode ladies and gentlemen the story
you are about to see is true the names
have been changed to protect the
innocent
[Music]
I want to say the surprising thing there
for me is that it starts with ladies and
gentlemen as that sounds like the sort
of voice that would say letting your
wife watch television could give her
Notions
are very similitude came at a price
Dragnet star and Creator Jack Webb
agreed that scripts will be formally
approved by the lapd's public
information Division and in return the
show could shoot wherever they wanted
have cops for extras and use police
vehicles and Equipment which was a
pretty good deal for both sides the show
got a patina of authenticity and the
LAPD got a flattering portrayal which it
frankly needed given that right after
Dragnet premiered approximately 50 LAPD
officers brutally beat seven men in
their custody for over an hour leaving
him hospitalized with broken bones and
ruptured organs in an incident that
later became known as Bloody Christmas
so if Dragnet really wanted to be
authentic every episode should probably
have started like this ladies and
gentlemen the story you are about to see
is [ __ ] the names have been changed
to protect the LAPD because they helped
to save a bunch of money on props
drug that had a big impact on viewers at
the time including one particular little
boy who later reminisce about being five
or six years old and allowed to stay up
late because Dragnet was on that boy
eventually grew up to become such a
household name someone once did this to
their own body here it is the worst
Executive Producer Dick Wolf
on his lower back yeah the man said he
got it because he's obsessed with Law
and Order yeah a dick wolf tattoo that
is real star power especially for an
executive producer perhaps that is why
iced tea himself once simply tweeted
Dick Wolf and it got 108 likes
Dick Wolf is one of those names like
Steve Madden or Charles Schwab that you
see all the time even if you have no
idea what Dick Wolf himself actually
looks like case in point that is not
Dick Wolf that's Charles Schwab this is
Dick Wolf except it isn't that Steve
Madden this is Dick Wolf is what I would
say if that was Dick Wolf but it's just
a stock image that came up when we
searched business Grandpa This I Promise
is the real Deadpool and Dick Wolf
worthy six-year-old Dragnet superfan who
then grew up to create Law and Order and
interestingly he actually started out in
advertising where among other things he
helped create this wildly sexist ad
campaign for National Airlines I'm Judy
and I was born to fly
fly me to Houston
nationalist non-stop dc-10s every day or
find me to New Orleans on the Army
dc-10s you can fly me morning afternoon
or night just say when
I'm Judy enough is foreign
fly Judy fly National
holy [ __ ]
I can only imagine the target demo of
that where men aged 18 to 40 who live by
the motto can't [ __ ] it don't want it
the whole fly me campaign was a big big
success and Dick Wolf later bragged
about it to the least appropriate person
imaginable you were in advertising
before as a writer as a writer producer
I made commercials you made commercials
what were some of the commercials where
did people recognize these commercials
oh today sure I'm Cheryl fly me I'm sure
I'll find a hey today that's immediate
sexual description that's immediately
going interestingly enough seven years
interestingly enough I think I it was at
the time one of the most successful
Airline campaigns ever because it was
funny I'm sure I'm Cheryl Fleming it was
aimed at businessmen and all the
stewardesses were from the University of
Florida and we're 22 years old that's
why they flew the air I'm surprised that
didn't end your career
if you've out massaged Roger Isles
man best known for sexually harass Ed so
hard he he died
outrageously Wrong Turn it's like
someone saying you look lost and it's
turning out that that someone was Amelia
Earhart you're in big [ __ ] trouble
now after leaving advertising Wolff
worked on cop shows like Hill Street
Blues and Miami Vice and in 1990 he had
his monster hit Law and Order which he
even gave his own version of the Dragnet
Preamble one that I'm guessing you can
basically recite by heart because you
know how it goes
in the criminal in the criminal justice
system the people are represented by two
separate yet equally important groups
the police investigate crime and the
district attorneys who prosecute the
offenders these are their stories done
done
now these are their stories part there
is really important because a big
selling point for Law and Order is that
similar to Dragnet it draws inspiration
from real life cases in fact as wolf
recounts when the network asked him
what's the Bible for the show he said
the front page of the New York Post no
writers are going to do better than
headless body found in topless bar which
is a catchy thing to say but I'm not
sure it's true assless corpse found at
bottomless brunch there I just did it
and like Jack Webb in La Dick Wolf
cultivated a close behind-the-scenes
relationship with the NYPD employing
officers as consultants and boasting
about the access he had I probably spent
more times with more time with cops than
anybody who doesn't carry a badge so I
mean when you meet people you meet cops
you meet whether it's Bill Bratton or
Ray Kelly or Sheriff Baca you know there
is a shared interest in uh putting bad
guys away and having cops for you know
shown in a decent light I am kind of
unabashedly
Pro law enforcement wow wolf is the most
enthusiastic chronicler of blue lives
since James Cameron and while not as
formal as dragnet's Arrangement Laurel
that has similarly benefited from its
relationship with the NYPD one writer
who's worked on the show has said there
was always the sense that if we told
stories that reflected too badly on the
police the NYPD could make it very
difficult for us to shoot in New York
which does make sense doesn't it the
NYPD is famously anti-shooting unless
they're the ones doing it in fact for as
much as Dick Wolf brags about how the
show is written in Shades of Gray or how
it'll show both sides of an issue there
is one side that is always on and that's
the police because however flawed his
characters may be they're all
fundamentally pursuing Justice and cops
love being portrayed that way as actors
on the show have a tested over the years
police around the country I must say are
big fans of the show because they feel
it's authentic a couple homicide cops
came over to visit they just had
wonderful things to say about the show
they said thank you and they were
thinking me which was weird uh
they felt like they were being well
represented my favorite quote from the
police is keep making us look good which
is a nice compliment they're very very
kind yeah I bet they are although for
one it's worth there was a pretty major
difference between they feel it's
authentic and they feel it makes them
look good and it's the same difference
between these two photos one is a mirror
of reality and the other is a lie
and look thanks to Law and Order's close
collaboration with its police
Consultants the show does get a lot of
smaller details right like specific laws
jargon and crime scene procedures but
crucially it also makes a lot of choices
that significantly distort the big
picture of policing for instance most
episodes arrest the right perpetrators
at the midpoint and then convict them at
the end and it's structured like that
for obvious reasons it is a
self-contained episode of TV and those
need satisfying narrative Arc
fulfillment but as we know in reality
not only do many cases simply go
unsolved almost none of the ones that do
get solved go to trial prosecutors put
massive pressure on Defenders to take
plea deals meaning that 97 of criminal
cases don't go to trial and obviously
Law and Order cannot reflect that
reality it would be unwatchable nobody
wants to watch a show where 97 of
episodes end with two lawyers striking a
deal in the windowless room and then you
get to watch the defendant serve six
months then struggle to get a job at
their local Jiffy Loop
but the courtroom half of Law and Order
actually represents a significant
departure from TV tradition because
historically lawyer shows centered
defense lawyers like Perry Mason who
tried to work against the system as the
underdog and free innocent people but
Law and Order is different and that is
very much by Design dick wolfer said I
believe that the heroes weren't the
defense attorneys who were getting these
scumbags off the heroes were the
prosecutors and you can see that on his
shows where defense attorneys are
usually presented as an impediment to
convicting obviously guilty suspects and
they're the target of lines like this
the cold chill just ran up your spine
it's because the defense attorney just
walked in here defense attorneys distort
the facts
they twist evidence I believe in
Monsters and Things That Go Bump in the
night Jack
made they rot in hell along with their
Journeys well let me guess
Darren boy otherwise known as a defense
attorney
a couple of things there one yes that is
a post OC Misha Barton doing some
award-worthy eyebrow acting there but
two to attorneys are a vital part of the
justice system so it's a bit weird that
Law and Order can sometimes go out of
its way to present them like the
babadook
and again you can absolutely justify
those decisions by saying come on
they're making fiction not a documentary
not everyone wants to watch hyper
realistic portrayals of our ever
desiccating Society John and I do
understand that but it's not just the
portrayals of defense lawyers where big
editorial decisions are being made one
study found that offenders on Law and
Order were disproportionately white male
older and from the middle or upper
classes dick Wolf's actually explained
his reasoning for why the show's
criminals skew that way saying there are
no rich white guy pressure groups you
can do anything you want to rich white
guys and nobody cares and you can see
what he might not want to make a show in
which his good guy cops are
disproportionately targeting communities
of color he wants people to like them
but the result of all of these creative
decisions is that instead of depicting a
flawed system riddled with structural
racism the show presents exceptionally
competent cops working within a largely
Fair framework that mostly convicts
white people and while it is true that
they have occasionally done episodes
focusing on individual bad cops or
referenced real world criticisms
especially recently with discussions of
anti-police sentiment sometimes being
shoehorned into conversations in general
police reforms are often portrayed by
the main characters as at best a
nuisance to them and at worst a threat
to Public Safety 16 murders over Fourth
of July they cut back on stop and
searches people start carrying you two
had him yesterday and you let him go
there wasn't probable cause for an
arrest you create probable cause you
push them around you're provoking after
Eric Garner and stop and Fritz lawsuit
so the 1pp's been very clear I don't
make a scene like it or not Nolan
the big bad Police Department is our
partner
and in case you haven't been paying
attention they're under attack every
decision every arrest is scrutinized
there are people trying to defund them
for God's sake and here you are asking
me to castrate them oh no scrutinizing
arrests how awful
you know it's pretty telling that even
in this fictional Universe Basic Police
accountability is treated as an
equivalent to getting your balls cut off
but maybe the best expression of the
disparity between Law and Order and real
life is in its most popular spin-off SVU
it is a show built on the appeal of
having cops who will stop at nothing to
crack horrific cases cops like Elliot
Stabler who before getting a spin-off
show routinely did [ __ ] like this I'm
gonna keep you waiting
okay
I get a little clumsy around scumbag
pedophiles why you gotta be so rough
because you still got one good arm left
to break so I should put you in pigtails
you little [ __ ] come on you little
[ __ ] I want you to cry for me
tell me come on cry for me I don't know
what the hell you're talking about
I think I have some dumb cop
D
leave will on that alone
look
I admit as a viewer it is something to
see Stabler chew up the scenery and spit
it out directly into Matthew modine's
face is it the model of good police
Behavior absolutely not is it compelling
to watch for sure it is is it hot
reasonable people can disagree
but generally the thesis on SVU is that
the cops deeply care about getting
Justice for victims and their gut
instincts mean that they almost always
get the job done in the end in one
episode we learned that Stabler has a 97
case closure rate and people love this
show Christopher Maloney is the internet
zaddy and you can see why his ass alone
is a pop culture icon and Mariska
Hargitay has a huge cult following too
fans have tattoos of her Taylor Swift
has a cat named for her character Olivia
Benson and there are even tick tocks
like this well you when you're a kid
Daddy's Little Girl
something like this
[Applause]
look in general I think I've made my
position on police brutality pretty
clear but even I will admit it is hard
to resist the sight of Olivia Benson
slamming an asshole's head on a table to
the beat of hollaback girl in which case
go off girl boss lean into
state-sponsored violence
[Applause]
relatively appealing about the idea of a
world where survivors of sexual assault
are taken seriously by the police hockey
takes even spoken openly about some of
the show's positive real world impacts I
have so many times
encountered people
that have said because of this show they
knew what to do after their assault
because of this show they had a rape get
done because of the show they reported
and had faith in that and because of the
show most of all they didn't feel alone
anymore
and to me
[Music]
when I started hearing those stories is
when I knew that
it wasn't just a TV show anymore it was
so much more look that is obviously
genuinely moving and I don't doubt the
show is doing important work informing
or even providing catharsis for some of
its viewers in between that is showing
her slamming a suspect's face into a
table like she's a toddler making two
Barbies kiss and to her real credit
Mariska Hargitay has tried to Parlay her
Fame into advocacy founding an
organization which advocates for
survivors of sexual assault domestic
abuse and child abuse but if as Hargitay
says the show encourages people to Avail
themselves off this system it is worth
knowing what that system can look like
in practice because it's not good
government and press reports have
repeatedly shown that New York's actual
sex crimes unit is set up to fail
victims of sexual assault and its case
closure rate is a long way from Elliot
stabler's fictitious 97 percent the
nypd's official figures show that they
only close about a third of sexual
assault cases but one analysis of cases
hand over a two-year period finally had
a closure rate of just six percent also
a damning 2018 investigation quoted
multiple prosecutors describing improper
handling of cases by overloaded or
inexperienced investigators until
recently were only given five days of
formal specialized training is it any
wonder that some cops are watching SVU
for tips which honestly may not be a bad
thing when you get Justice Crusader
Olivia Benson but he gets a little hairy
when you get use of excessive for zaddy
here
and while the NYPD insists that they've
since improved Staffing and training the
doj recently announced their own
investigation citing reports that the
unit's officers were failing to conduct
basic investigative steps and instead
shaming and abusing survivors and
re-traumatizing them during
investigations and yet the portrait SVU
paints of the division is so convincing
that when a new Commander took it over
in 2020 and did an interview discussing
that scaling internal report that I just
mentioned here is how the anchor wrapped
up their conversation you know I'm going
to ask this because I'm obsessed with
the TV show law order SVU how real
is the TV show to real life
I I can tell you this uh the dedication
you see on TV with the investigators
that's the same dedication uh that we
have within the real uh Special Victims
Unit uh and the cases are very very
similar as heinous as you see them on TV
uh we are seeing the same thing in real
life so many of them are ripped from the
headlines you know
boy stop you're falling there just keep
it going are you really as cool as you
see him on TV do you sometimes make the
car go wee-woo even when it doesn't need
to go wee-woo is iced tea nice I follow
him on Twitter
and it's worth knowing some survivors
have spoken about what it is like seeing
these detectives valorized on TV with
one saying Law and Order SVU gave me the
false impression that this squad cared
deeply about victims and their jobs and
another saying if I had a dollar for
every time I heard this can't be true
Olivia Benson would never let this
happen I would have enough to cover my
hospital bills and therapy for my trauma
and you should know even the real world
inspiration for the tenacious
uncompromising Olivia Benson and the
show's tough Ada Alexandra Cabot has a
significant asterisk because an early
model for both characters was Linda
ferstein the woman now Infamous for
prosecuting the Central Park five or as
they're now known the exonerated five
and I will say some behind the show are
keenly aware of its role in perpetuating
a false narrative about police in fact
in 2020 at the peak of the black lives
matter protest Warren lights reflected
on the role that the show plays in our
discussion of policing so uh you know
individually am I doing am I
contributing miscontributing to society
I don't know collectively are we yeah uh
so so how do you what do you do can you
go into the network I have pitched the
uh by the way I think every writer has
pitched the Innocence Project series to
the networks I've made that pitch I bet
it has a better chance of going now and
within the Dick Wolf Law and Order
universe
it won't be likely that they're going to
do a show that reveals that that bases
itself
um on Cops
behaving illegal that's not part of of
uh that of of Dick's brand
exactly even if the people working on
the show the actors the writers and the
showrunners have really good intentions
about correcting the record there is
only so much they can do Law and Order
is never going to Grapple with the
reality of policing in a meaningful way
for the same reasons that Daniel Tiger
won't do it it's never going to happen
and honestly you'd be pretty weirded out
if it ever did because fundamentally the
person who is responsible for Law and
Order and its brand is Dick Wolf and he
knows exactly what he wants his shows to
do and importantly not to do here he is
invoking one of the most notorious cases
of police abuse in New York City Abner
luima who was beaten by NYPD officers
and sodomized in 1997. we're not there
to uh do Abner lewima that's you know
that's a terrible thing that happened
but that represents one or two bad
apples and a police force of 35 000
people we're certainly I think the show
over the last uh all three shows are
probably the best recruiting poster that
you could have for being a New York City
Cop right because a recruiting poster is
always going to be a propagandized
hero-washed version of the truth a truth
which is more often than not very ugly
and for the 300th time I know Law and
Order is just a TV show I know it's
meant to be entertainment and honestly
I'm not even telling you not to watch it
it's completely fine to enjoy it and
it's completely understandable to want
Olivia Benson to exist but it is
important to remember just how far it is
from representing anything resembling
reality as one critic of Law and Order
has put it if a medical show was giving
us inaccurate information we would say
it's dangerous which is true because
think about it you know Gray's Anatomy
doesn't depict what happens inside an
actual Hospital those doctors are
ridiculously hot none of them are nearly
tired enough and it needs about five
thousand percent more discussion of
insurance
but if those medical professionals were
routinely claiming that vaccines cause
autism and Herbal Remedies cure cancer
we'd probably be having a conversation
about it because that's essentially what
Law and Order is doing it's presenting a
world where the cops can always figure
out who did it defense attorneys are
irritating obstacles to be overcome and
even if a cop roughs up a suspect it's
all in pursuit of a just outcome and it
blasts that fantasy at you in Endless
reruns and marathons in the guys are
very well produced extremely
entertaining TV but Underneath It All it
is a commercial and a commercial
produced by a man who is in his own
words unabashedly pro-law enforcement
and he is very good at selling things
and in this instance he's selling a
complete fantasy that many people in
this country are only too happy to buy
which is fine as long as we don't lose
sight of the fact that it's an ad for a
defective product because if I'm a quote
one last time from the library of
Alexandria that is iced Tea's Twitter
account
you've got to know who the f you're
dealing with could be the cops that's
our show thank you so much for watching
and give tonight's story there is really
only one way to end this and it's like
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]